in this video we're going to talk about
how to find the missing sides in the
special right triangles the 45 45 90 and
the 30 60 90. we're going to go through
the 45 45 90 first then we'll do the 30
60 90. then I want to talk a little bit
about where these side lengths come from
we can get into the theory a little bit
if you're interested in that and then
we'll do some more problems at the end
so the first thing we want to talk about
is the 45-45 90 triangle so what you
notice here is that it's an isosceles
triangle these base angles are congruent
and so that means that these two legs or
these two sides that make up that right
angle they're going to be congruent as
well so we refer to those sides as x and
x they're going to be the same but to
get to the hypotenuse the side that's
across from the right angle you have to
take that side or that leg and multiply
by the square root of 2. if you're going
from the hypotenuse to the leg you're
going to want to divide by the square
root of 2. and just a quick note square
root of 2 it's about 1.4 which means
that the hypotenuse is about 1.4 times
longer than the leg it's just that when
we multiply by square root of 2 we're
getting an exact value for that
hypotenuse so let's jump into some
examples see if you can try some of
these on your own as well but for the
first one we you can see they're giving
us this 45 45 90 triangle and they're
giving us a leg or a side of eight so
you can see X is equal to 8 which means
that a over here this other leg must
also be eight and if we want to find the
hypotenuse we just take the leg and we
multiply by the square root of 2 so side
B here the hypotenuse is going to be 8
root 2.
now let's go to another example number
two here we've got a 45 45 90 and
sometimes they'll denote that by showing
you that these two acute angles are
congruent and that's how you know it's a
45 45 90. but you can see they're giving
us the hypotenuse so here what we want
to do to get back to the leg is we're
going to want to divide by the square
root of 2. so if we take 4 root 2
divided by square root of 2 those square
root of twos cancel out and we're just
left with 4 and remember in a 45 45 90
these two legs that make up that right
angle are going to be congruent
okay for number three now same thing 45
45 90 they're giving us the leg is two
root 3 which means that this other leg
over here must be 2 root three since the
legs are congruent but to get to that
hypotenuse we have to multiply by the
square root of two remember it's about
1.4 times longer so if we take 2 square
root of 3 times square root of 2 you can
think of this as like one square root of
two you multiply the integers together
and the square roots together so 2 times
1 is 2 square root of 3 times square
root of 2 is square root of 6 and that's
going to be your hypotenuse
okay for number four again we have a 45
45 90. they're giving us the hypotenuse
now is six we have to make our way back
to the leg so remember the hypotenuse is
uh square root of two times longer than
the leg so to go back to the leg we have
to divide by the square root of two so
and we don't want that square root of 2
in the denominator that's considered
improper so what we're going to do is
we're going to do a process called
rationalizing where we multiply the
numerator and denominator by square root
of two that's like multiplying by one
and so if we multiply horizontally
across we get 6 square root of 2 square
root of 2 times square root of 2 is
square root of 4 which is just equal to
2 and then you can see the six and the 2
reduce and that's giving us 3 square
root of 2. so that's going to be this
leg as well as this leg because remember
the legs are congruent okay last 45 45
90 example a little bit more challenging
here you can see that we've got the
hypotenuse is 8 root 3 we want to go
back to the leg so remember when you're
going from the X root 2 side the
hypotenuse to the leg we have to divide
by the square root of two so here we've
got 8 square root of 3 divided by square
root of 2 just like this last problem we
didn't want the radical in the
denominator the square root of 2 in the
denominator so we're going to multiply
the top and bottom by square root of 2.
remember you multiply the numbers
together and the square roots together
so that's is going to be 8 square root
of 6 all over square root of 4 which is
2 the 8 and the 2 we can reduce 2 goes
into 8 4 times so we get 4 squared of 6
for J and 4 square root of 6 for I
because remember the legs are congruent
okay now the 30 60 90 triangle a little
bit more challenging but not too bad
what you want to remember here with the
30 60 90 is that across from the 30
degree angle that's going to be the
shortest side that's the shortest leg
and we call that leg X the one across
from the 60 degree angle that's the
longer leg that's x times the square
root of 3 and the one across from the 90
that's the hypotenuse that's the longest
side that's 2x now just a quick note
square root of 3 is about 1.7 so if
you're going from the shorter leg to the
longer leg you're basically multiplying
by 1.7 the only thing is that square
root 3 is going to give you an exact
value for that leg so the way I like to
think about it and you can think about
this as well is if you have the shorter
leg it's an easy problem you just have
to double it to get the hypotenuse or
multi Pi by square root of 3 to get the
longer leg if they give you the
hypotenuse it's still a pretty easy
problem you just divide by two to get
the shorter leg and then multiply by
square root of 3 to get the longer leg
the tougher one sometimes is if they
give you this longer leg you're going to
have to divide by square root of 3 to
get back to that shorter leg
and then double it to get the hypotenuse
so let's go through let's go through
some examples so you can see how this
works and I'll kind of explain as I go
so for number six you can see that
they're giving us a side across from
that 30 degree angle that's the shortest
leg that's four
so if I want to get to this side here
the hypotenuse all I have to do is
double it see X 2x so if I multiply by 2
I get 8 and if I want to get to this
longer leg I just take the shorter leg
and I multiply by square root of 3 so
this is going to be 4 square root of 3.
pretty easy right so let's try number
seven so this one what are they giving
us they're giving us a side across from
the right angle that's our hypotenuse
and we can see that's the 2x side now
sometimes what students do to kind of
help themselves out a little bit is they
might kind of like superimpose these
variables over the triangles they might
say oh that's my 2x side this is like my
1X side this is my like extrude 3 side
so then you would say well how do I go
from 2x to 1x well I'd have to divide by
2 to get 1X so if I take 10 divided by 2
I get 5. and then if I say well how do I
get from X to X root 3 well I have to
multiply by square root of 3 so 5 times
square root of 3 is 5 square root of 3.
so that can sometimes help after doing
it a while you're kind of know what to
do so for example this one they're
giving us the one across from the 60
degree angle that's our longer leg
that's our X root 3 side so we're going
to divide by the square root of 3. so
this is going to be 8 square root of 3
divided by square root of 3 the square
root of 3s cancel and you can see we're
just getting 8.
once you have the short leg that's
pretty easy because you just have to
then double it to get the hypotenuse so
8 doubled is going to give us 16. okay
for number nine now a little bit more
challenging they're giving us the
hypotenuse the one across from the right
angle that's our 2x side we want to make
our way back to the short leg the 1X
side across from the 30 degree angle
which means we have to divide by two so
this is 6 square root of 2 divided by 2
the 6 and the 2 reduce so this is just
going to come out to 3 root 2. now we
want to make our way to the longer leg
we do that by multiplying by the square
root of 3 so 3 square root of 2 times
square root of 3 we multiply these
radicals together and we get 3 square
root of 6 for this longer leg
number 10 a little bit more challenging
they're giving us Society across from
the 60 degree angle this is the longer
leg this is a nine we want to go from
that longer leg to the shorter leg and
we're going to do that by dividing by
the square root of three so what's 9
divided by the square root of 3 well we
don't want that squared in the
denominator right so we're going to
rationalize by multiplying the numerator
and denominator by square root of 3. so
that's going to give us 9 square root of
3 over square root of 9 which is just 3
and then the 9 and the 3 reduce so this
is just going to come out to 3 square
root of 3. okay now if we want to go to
the hypotenuse remember the hypotenuse
is just twice the short leg so if we
multiply 3 root 3 times 2 we get 6
square root of 3. don't make the mistake
of saying 6 square root of 6 you just
want to multiply the coefficients the
numbers in front together and then you'd
multiply the square roots together so
it's like multiplying like terms and our
last example before we get into some
more deeper explanation about the theory
behind these two triangles here they're
giving us the shorter leg and what we
want to do is we want to go to the
longer legs so we have to multiply by
the square root of 3. square root of 3
times square root of 3 is square root of
9 which is just 3 times this 5 is going
to give us 15. and if we want to go to
the hypotenuse we just have to double
that shorter leg and 5 root 3 times 2 is
going to give us 10 square roots of 3.
again remember when we multiply by 2
we're just multiplying those integers
together and not you know there's no
square root so the square root just
comes along with it okay for those of
you that want to know a little bit more
about you know why this works and where
these values come from let's start off
by looking at a square now we know in a
square you've got these four right
angles and you have these four congruent
sides we're going to call each of the
sides X because they're all the same
right but what we're going to do now is
we're going to draw a diagonal like so
and we're going to look at this triangle
now when we draw a diagonal that's going
to bisect this angle here this is going
to be a 45 45 90 triangle and it's kind
of like if you're trying to put
something in a box like if you've tried
to put it this way sometimes it doesn't
fit if you try to put it this way it
doesn't fit what do we naturally do we
put it on the diagonal because we know
that diagonal is going to be longer and
in fact we know it's about 1.4 times
longer square root of 2 times longer but
let's see if we can understand why that
is so if we take this triangle now
let's draw it here we've got x x and
let's call this side C now you remember
your Pythagorean theorem a squared plus
b squared equals c squared right so the
sum of the two legs squared equals the
hypotenuse squared so let's go ahead and
write that formula down so a squared
plus b squared equals c squared here
this is going to be x squared plus x
squared is equal to this hypotenuse
squared this comes out to 2x squared
equals c squared and if we take the
square root just to get the length of C
the square root of x squared is going to
be x square root of 2 we're just going
to we can't really simplify that we'll
just leave it as square root of 2. so
that's where these values are coming
from for the 45 45 90 the two legs are
the same remember because this is coming
from the square where all the sides are
congruent but the hypotenuse is x
squared of 2 and that comes from our
Pythagorean theorem now let's jump over
to the 30 60 90.
now we're going to start with an
equilateral triangle now remember
lateral means side equal means equal but
if it's equilateral we also know it's
equiangular and at all the angles in a
triangle add up to 180 so if all these
angles are equal they must all be 60
degrees right
now if we drop an altitude okay in an
isosceles triangle an equilateral
triangle is a special type of isosceles
triangle what happens is it's going to
be perpendicular to the base meaning it
forms a right angle and it's also going
to bisect the base meaning it's going to
cut it in half so if this whole length
is 2x now this is going to be X and this
is going to be X let's take a look at
this triangle right here let's draw it
down here so now what we're getting is
we're getting X
2x this angle is 60 degrees and this
angle is going to be 30 degrees because
all the angles add up to
180 but we also know that we drop that
altitude here at bisect this
vertex angle so now we're going to solve
for this side here let's just call it B
and we're going to do our Pythagorean
theorem again a squared plus b squared
equals c squared solving for this leg so
we've got a squared plus b squared
equals c squared we're going to say x
squared plus b squared which is this
side equals 2x the quantity squared
right that whole thing squared 2x times
2x is 4x squared
and if we subtract x squared from both
sides
we're going to get B squared is equal to
3x squared
and if we take the square root of both
sides to get B by itself you can see
we're getting square root of x squared
is X and we have the square root of 3
left over so that tells you here that
our longer leg is going to be x squared
of 3 the one that's across from the 60
degree angle that's our longer leg X
root three one across from the 30 is the
short leg X and our hypotenuse is the
longest one two x okay here's a little
bit of an opportunity for you to
practice on your own so what you might
want to do is take a screenshot see if
you can solve these five problems I kind
of mixed them up randomly see if you can
do them and we'll go through them
together now for number 12 if I was
going to do this one on my own one thing
you'll notice is that the way that I've
drawn this triangle is different than
the way I explained this originally that
orientation so I kind of rotated it kind
of changed the direction a little bit to
try to make it a little bit more
challenging now if you have a phone or a
piece of paper you can rotate it so it's
a little bit more familiar a little bit
more comfortable if you're used to
seeing it in a particular direction but
what I like to think about is you know
short legs across from the 30 long
things across from the 60 hyponuses
across from the right angle and if you
want to use that little technique I was
talking about earlier with the 2X 1X and
X root 3 to kind of guide you you can
say Well they're giving us the 2x side I
want to go back to the 1X side so I have
to divide by 2 what's 16 divided by 2
that's going to be 8. now to go from X
to X root 3 I just have to multiply by
square root of 3 so 8 times square root
of 3 gives us 8 square root of 3.
for number 13 this you can see is a
45-45 90 triangle also I rotated it a
little bit to make a little bit more
challenging and you can see they're
giving us the hypotenuse that's going to
be our X root 2 side to get back to the
leg we have to divide by the square root
of 2. so it's going to be 10 divided by
square root of 2. remember we don't want
that squared in the denominator so we're
going to rationalize so 10 root 2 over 2
and the 10 and the 2 reduce so that
comes out to 5 root 2. so both of these
legs remember they're congruent are
going to be 5 root 2.
for number 14 another 30-60-90 but what
are they giving us here it looks like
they're giving us the one across from
the 60 degree angle that's our longer
leg that's our ax root 3 side always
with the 30 60 90 I always want to make
my way back to the short leg so I say
well how do I get from extrude 3 to X I
have to divide by square root of 3. so
let's see 12 divided by square root of 3
we don't want that square root of 3 in
the denominator so we're going to
rationalize that gives us 12 root 3 over
3. notice when you multiply a square
root times itself you get that number
underneath or you can do square root of
9 is 3. the 12 and the three reduce so
you can see we're going to get a 4 root
3 for the short leg now to go from the
short leg to the hypotenuse we just have
to double 4 root 3 times 2 gives us 8
square roots of 3.
okay for number 15 this is another 45 45
90. it looks like we're get given the
leg which means we automatically know
the other leg is the same two root five
to get to the hypotenuse though we have
to multiply by the square root of two
remember it's about 1.4 times longer so
if we multiply 2 root 5 times square
root of two that's going to give us two
square root of 10. I want to multiply
those square roots together and then the
last problem another 30 60 90. let me
see if I can finish drawing that 30 60
90. looks like we're being given the
short leg the one across from the 30
degree angle so to get to the hypotenuse
we have to double it so that's going to
be 6 square root of 7 okay and then to
go from the short leg to the longer leg
we have to multiply by the square root
of three so three square root of 7 times
square root of 3 gives us 3 square root
of 21
and you got it so I hope you enjoyed
this video if you want to see more
examples I'll put a video up there that
you can check out for more practice more
examples with 45 45 90 30 60 90. I look
forward to helping you in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon